das ist das hier unten
hallo mein name sogar apple bekommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video libyschen
mittel eine werde die besten optisch
enttäuschungen ich habe nämlich im
internet einer internetseite gefunden
die daheim
11 bilder die du auf den ersten blick
nicht verstehen wird verliert will dich
auf den ersten blick nicht verstehen
weshalb optische täuschungen und
illusionen alles anrichten können
wir sagen aber gar nicht langsam
anfangen kann mit dem ersten bild das
erste bilder sei thw hockey irgendwie
tricky wird der seitliche klamotten wir
müssen das ganze jetzt erst mal
verstehen also hier steht eine frau oder
ein mann irgendwie hinter dem stuhl
also dafür sich der kopf von dieser
person hier sondern von der personalie
der dieses mädchen diese dame die ihr
den typen hier vorne macht ihr den link
neben ihn oder so das ding noch klarer
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
er hätte einfach so einen kleinen kopf
natürlich das kann man sich ja auch
wieder komplett logisch erklären und war
einfach wieder kommt von den rosen typen
hier der held in eine runterhauen der
typ hier vorne der titel der website ein
vor ihm
sie steht auf dem teppich gescheiterte
diese optischen täuschungen galt war so
krass sind aber als ich als normal
denkender chronologischer reihenfolge
passieren kann wenn also ich würde jetzt
hier einfach sagen dass die einfach wenn
man sich die belange junger hüpfer
wegdenken
die einfach auch vom brett steht da ihre
rede hält und das hier ist einmal der
schatten von aflac die hinter dem
fotografen steht doch eigentlich auch
logisch oder
das ist sehr intim acht tatsächlich man
denkt erst noch jeder 14
dadurch gucken wenn dann wie hier diese
person mit dem unterkörper
und hier die hat einfach keinen kopf
aber des spiegel
das ist spiegel wie man unter anderem
daran dass hier einfach die ganzen teile
sich wirklich perfekte symmetrie
spiegeln hier vorne die hände glitt
verdeckt natürlich man sieht auch daran
dass wir diese person hier hinten
einfach ein blaues oberteil anderen wir
drunter von hellblaue bereit diese
person hier sind zwar sie einfach ihr
vorne links okay ich will jetzt einfach
mal so erklären dass das hier ihm wie
die mutter erst in die hinter dem team
dahinter das kind bitter halt irgendwie
so drauf und ich meine enttäuschung und
ich glaube wer sowas nicht verstehen
sagt dass man nicht immer noch ein
bisschen doof ist die 39 aufgestanden
das ist auf jeden fall ein typ wie dat
an und man sieht sogar eine süße und
eine dahinter gekommen ist tatsächlich
sehr sehr gut gemacht das muss man sagen
und er noch ordentlich am schwitzen da
vorne ihr sieht so aus als wenn er hier
über mensch nicht groß wie oder eher
übermenschlich klein das heißt ich würde
einfach mal sagen dass er hier einfach
das ist so ähnlich wie das mit der mit
der flagge vor hin dass er einfach auf
andere genommen hat und dann also
passiert der typ ist quasi einfach mehr
so kamera abgesprungen als die person
hier hinten was ist los ist kann ich mir
nicht erklären es sieht so aus als wären
die werke von dieser frau oder diesen
typen mit dem tod habe führen
topfschnitt richtig scheiße eigentlich
immer noch meine eltern sich getraut mit
mir ausdrücklich den kopf von dieser
person mit dem kleid wäre es aber
wahrscheinlich so dass dieser kommt er
mit dem t shirt gehört aber auch dann
wäre der kopf gegen die übermenschlich
groß also
der kopf fehlt einfach also ich glaube
wir sind uns alle einig dass mit dem
typen hier links mit dem blauen ist
alles in ordnung also der schlägt nicht
da endlich die frage wird gerade beim
iphone kommt man auch nicht unbedingt
tun aber ich war schon das eine oder
andere einfach zu spielen das kommt
eigentlich immer vor irgendwie prügel
die sich immer dann hier glaube ich
einfach dass mein kopf irgendwie in die
mangel genommen wurde und deswegen weil
helm irgendwie weggeduckt hat unterhält
würde dann besser auf ihn runter fallen
aber er ist schon so oft aber keine
das ist das hier unten leute da ist das
ist eine optische ich bin schon wieder
kaufen youtube schaut sich sowohl video
hier an denkt wieder dadurch viel
nachdenken ihre mini wirklich
nachvollziehen vor kurzem auch die
bestände die zu hunderten peters denkt
gar nicht mehr danach schreit video
wieder ab
die wäre ausgeschaltet video würde ich
mir anrief weil ich würde gar nicht mehr
verkaufen sagt aber hey you tube hey
wenn ihr das beten daumen ist die hand
von dieser person hier daran hält er das
blatt
das ist kein glied ok ich rede schon so
mit youtube welcher vorwurf machen
würden wiederkommen ich meine allein die
tatsache dass ich letztlich auch ein
video reagieren habe wo diese fehlt sind
also wo leute wirklich etwas gemacht
kann man wirklich schief gegangen cetera
und video plötzlich reagiert habe ist
nicht serviert und war komplett für alle
geeignet keine altersbeschränkung ich
habe das video allerdings komplett an
allen stellen sind wittelsbach sehen
dank youtube danke nochmal an der stelle
kommen wir nur noch zu letzten optischen
täuschung meine damen und herren ich
habe lange auf diesen moment gewartet
durch diese auszutauschen zeigen zu
können er hätte sich hierbei um nicht
geringeres als einen hund der in einer
sitzt wahrscheinlich wird der hund
einfach hier auf den platz und die frau
dicht dahinter
aber hey ist ein hund der gerade bahn
fährt das nicht wieder meine damen und
herren ich noch dadurch getoppt hat laut
wahlleiter und bei leute bei 5 live per
los ich dieses ding was auch immer das
ist in zwei wochen findet ein fantreffen
in wien statt
dort könnt ihr mich retten und auch
viele andere youtuber machten link dafür
nach beschreibung und auch einen code
mit dem wir zum sparen können sie ich
möchte mich auf jeden fall freuen wir
uns versehen können rechneten
unterhalten fotos machen et cetera haare
kriegt man hier einen manager benny
darauf ihr könnt mich mein kanal
kostenlos abonniert video findet ihr
auch mal ein schock eingeblendet und
hier unten ein anderes video könnt ihr
euch auch wir sehr gerne mal anschauen
übrigens unter dem video eine glocke
neben dem abonniert symbol der könnt ihr
auch gerne drauf klicken dann bekommt
die notifikation endlich video nadel